uh there's i this isn't no of course  this isn't this water but so there are  you know there are set twos you have  some touchy moments and words and  obviously you can kill them but  uh can we talk about the sex scene it's  one of the best sex scenes i've seen in  forever oh that's sexy who put that  together you know seriously  [Laughter]  you  no it's not and it's not i'm well it's  not like they're kind of like prancing  around naked it's just it's a really  clever  so who who put did you guys put that  together did ricky scott put it together  no we had nothing to do with that  excuse me i'm just trying to cover my  universe over here  and of course it's not just you in it uh  other screen legends jeremy are you sexy  jeremy  jeremy was particular  he was great he was behind the camera  why are you having sex  [Music]  you